this will be the first World Cup ever
held in the Muslim world the first World
Cup held in the Middle East it's also
the most controversial World Cup in
history here are four things to look out
for in Qatar
[Music]
build up to the World Cup has been
dominated by concerns over mistreatment
and deaths of low-paid Migrant workers
to build the stadiums and the
infrastructure in Qatar there's also a
controversy over same-sex relationships
being illegal in the country Denmark are
planning on wearing a toned down black
shirt referencing the color of mourning
for the migrant workers deaths the
Australian team released this video
criticizing Qatar over worker conditions
and calling for the decriminalization of
same-sex relationships
and countries including England and
Germany have signed up to the one love
campaign where the captains will wear
armbands that highlight lgbtq plus
freedoms further protests and
demonstrations could happen in the
tournament proper despite FIFA's plea to
the 32 football Nations to focus on the
football
Qatar has essentially had to build all
the infrastructure to host the World Cup
of the eight host stadiums seven are
brand new while the other has had some
serious Redevelopment add to that hotels
roads public spaces transport and fan
Parks it has ended up costing hundreds
of billions of dollars these new
state-of-the-art facilities will come
under immediate pressure because an
estimated 1.2 million fans are expected
to visit Qatar during the tournament
[Music]
Qatar won the World Cup hosting after a
hotly contested FIFA vote beating the
United States in the final round
but given the country's strict Islamic
laws it's questionable human rights
record and Searing temperatures that
were immediate corruption concerns over
the decision FIFA commissioned its own
investigation that raised concerns about
the conduct of the qataris saying that
the bid may not have met the standards
required but found no evidence of
improper activity to Warrant taking the
tournament off
foreign
with all the pre-tournament focus on the
controversies and the protests it's easy
to forget there's a World Cup to be won
Brazil France and Argentina are the
pre-tournament favorites England have
struggled recently but remain a strong
Contender after reaching the semi-finals
of the 2018 World Cup and only losing
Euro 2020 Final on penalties to Italy
Wales are also playing in their first
World Cup since 1958. they're in the
same group as Rivals England
foreign
dominated by issues off the pitch and it
coming in the middle of the European
football season build up to Qatar 2022
has felt quite muted
fans at home won't have the usual summer
tournament outdoor screenings whether it
can catch the imagination of the general
public remains to be seen and that might
just depend on how well the Hope Nations
fare